are you interested in retrieving data
from the firestore database in a way
that's both faster and more
cost-effective if so you're watching the
right video today I'm going to show you
how to use firebase cloud functions to
automatically aggregate or add up
information from a sub collection and
then write it to its parent document
take for example a post document that
has a comment sub collection nested
under it whenever a new comment is
created it's going to trigger a cloud
function that will read this comment sub
collection then add up the comment count
and the five most recent comments and
then duplicate them on the post document
on a no sequel document database like
firestore duplication is perfectly
acceptable imagine if we had a post with
a hundred comments we'd have to read all
those comments to get the total every
time someone viewed a post not only is
that slower for the end user but it's
also going to cost a lot more money as
your app scales up my goal today is to
show you how to solve this problem using
back-end data aggregation if you're new
here make sure to subscribe and you can
grab the full source code from angular
firebase com I'm going to be starting
from a brand new angular app so run ng
new it's only dependency is angular fire
too and you can follow the setup
instructions for that on the main repo
if you're not using angular you can skip
ahead to the cloud function code which
is just written in plain JavaScript the
first thing I'll show you is our
underlying data we have a post
collection and then this test post under
it then you can see we have a recent
comments array here which is the five
most recent comments from potentially
hundreds or even thousands of comments
in the subcollection having this data on
the parent dock is extremely useful if
you loop through a list of posts and you
just want to show a quick preview of the
most recent comment as well as the total
comment count the comment sub collection
is very simple it just has a content
property and a created at timestamp at
this point I want to point out that this
is not suitable for every situation it's
ideal when you have documents that
receive many reads but not very many
writes a good example would be Yelp
where many users want to see the reviews
for a location but only a small
percentage actually write a review
getting back to angular you're going to
need to run firebase and NIT functions
if you're in a new project and then
we're not going to install anything
special we can just use the default
packages but make sure they're updated
newest version because firestore is a
relatively new product we'll write this
cloud function in a few minutes let's
first make the query without any data
aggregation I am switching over to the
app component and then I'm going to
import observable from rxjs
as well as angularfire store then I can
go ahead and inject angularfire store in
the constructor from there I'll declare
a variable for our post reference which
is an angular firestore document and
then we'll set another variable for the
observable and we'll do the exact same
thing here for the comments but it'll be
an angular firestore collection then
we'll add one more variable for form
value which we'll get from the form
input in the HTML during ng on an it
will first make a reference to the
document that we want which in this case
is just called test post and then we can
make a reference to its comment sub
collection by calling collection on that
reference so we say post ref collection
comments and it's also important that we
order by something in this case we have
a timestamp on the comments so we'll say
order by created at and make that
descending then to actually retrieve our
post we call post ref value changes and
that returns it as an observable then we
can do the exact same thing for comments
then we're going to switch over to the
HTML and we'll set a template variable
for our post so we unwrap that with the
async pipe and then say as post and then
from there we'll just display the post
title on the post content then we'll go
ahead and set up a form input here and
bind it with ng model then when the user
hits the enter key we'll go ahead and
run a function to update that in the
database right now we have a comments
observable so we'll go ahead and loop
over that with the async pipe but after
we perform some data aggregation we'll
be able to read this information
directly from the post document so at
this point we have our blog post here
and then the user can enter their
comment and it's updated in real time
the problem here is we're reading
multiple documents when we could only
just read one and we also don't have an
efficient way to keep track of a comment
count or any other aggregate data so
let's go ahead and solve this by writing
a cloud function we're going to import
the admin day
and make sure that's initialized then
we're going to run the function whenever
a new comment document is written to the
database so we do that by saying
functions firestore document then point
it to the comment ID nested under the
post using on write we'll run this
function whenever a document is created
updated or deleted first we'll set a
couple variables here for the comment ID
and the post ID so we do that by calling
event params with the corresponding ID
then after we have those IDs will setup
a reference to the post document we're
going to do that with the admin database
which will allow us to bypass any
firestore rules that we have set up then
from there we need to query the
collection of comments that are nested
under this document so we can add them
up and aggregate them in a cloud
function we're using the main firebase
SDK as opposed to angularfire too so we
do things slightly different instead of
calling value changes we call get that
returns a promise with the query
snapshot the query snapshot contains all
of the documents that we need and it
behaves kind of like an array but you
can't use the regular JavaScript
prototype array methods on it to get the
size of the collection we can call a
query snapshot size and then to get all
of the recent comments we'll set up an
array here then we can loop over the
snapshots with for each method and for
each comment we're going to push it to
our array at this point you have an
array of data that you could perform any
kind of data aggregation tasks that you
want but for now we're just going to
splice the last five comments and we'll
also set a property for the last
activity which would be the last time
any user has placed a comment on this
post and then finally we add all of this
data to an object then we can call
update on our document reference then
we'll also go ahead and console log
errors here but overall it's a pretty
simple cloud function I'd like to point
out that if you're doing multiple
updates in this function you'd want to
wrap it in either a transaction or do
them all in a single batch that will
ensure all your aggregate data stays in
sync and is up
atomically the final step is to deploy
this function to firebase so we just run
firebase deploy only functions now let's
modify our angular app to take advantage
of this function back in the app
component first notice that I've removed
the comments observable from ng on a net
instead we're going to lazy load it only
when necessary then users can actually
still add a comment without even loading
the comments collection because we have
the comments ref we can just call add
and pass it some data we're going to
show the user the first five comments
which will be on the document if the
user wants to load more we'll give them
a button to click which will lazily
populate the comments observable in
angular fire to the actual data isn't
read until you call value changes now we
just need to make some changes to our
app component HTML to show the aggregate
data
so first up here will show the total
comment count as well as the timestamp
on the last activity then we'll set up
another for loop because now we have an
array on the document itself
but we only want to show this if the
comments observable isn't populated so
we can just do ng if no comments
observable then we'll go ahead and show
the five most recent comments this data
is already unwrapped by the post
observable so we can just call post
recent comments and we don't need to use
the async pipe and then we'll just go
ahead and display the same exact data if
the user decides they want to load all
of the comments then we'll give them a
button down here to do so so we'll just
say click and then run our load more
event handler and we can show them how
many comments are on this post in the
app itself take a look at the total
comments which is currently 11 and if we
go ahead and add another comment you'll
see it gets updated down there in the
feed and the total comments is updated
to 12 with about maybe a second or so of
latency the latency is a little bit
higher but that is one of the trade-offs
when you're doing aggregation so here
we're looking at the post document and
firestore and you can see it's updated
each time we add a new comment if 99% of
your users read the blog post but don't
leave a comment this is going to vastly
reduce the number of reads that you
execute in firestore not only is that
going to save you money as you gain
more users but it's also going to make
your app much more performant that's it
for data aggregation with firestore if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want twice as much
content every week consider becoming a
pro subscriber at angular firebase com
you'll get a free copy of my book as
well as an extra video every week and I
even provide one-on-one support via our
slack team thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]